hi everyone my name is Tamara chambers
and this is Tamara's never seen and I am
watching tombstone which I believe is my
first ever Western that I've ever seen
is gone with the winner Western I
actually watched this a week back with
all the NC guys and had a blast with it
but going into it I was imagining that I
was going to be extremely bored
we watched True Lies and then went
straight into Tombstone and I was
honestly pretty upset that we watched
True Lies first because I thought that
True Lies was at least gonna be
interesting to me and I loved True Lies
and I was like oh I might just fall
asleep during Tombstone so that's what I
went into it with and let's go into it
with that here we go
[Music]
Tamra you silly silly fool
I loved this movie it was so much better
than I thought it was going to be so
different than what I was expecting but
the acting was a shuttle crazy good
I wrote Val Kilmer amazing best roll I
haven't seen him in it pretty much
anything else but best the movie opens
up on the Cowboys shooting up a wedding
and it was brutal and also holy young
actors Batman it was filled with so many
people a lot that I didn't know and a
lot that like BB robber like oh there's
that guy there's like Aaron like I don't
know who that guy is cool so many young
actors a lot of people before they were
famous like you know Sam Elliot from big
big things I know Sam Elliot because
he's in Parks and Recreation I also know
him because we did this Sam Wow skit
when I first joined the stall to critic
and there's a line that Doug does ask
Sam Elliot he's like Ron are you sure no
it's like oh that's hilarious I don't
really know who that is but great and in
this movie it was from this movie so he
says if these doesn't Merlot you're so
rich enough I know I know what I feel
super interesting about this is that
this movie is one of if not the most
accurate portrayals of the actual story
of what happened I watched some videos
on it and read up a bit of it online and
and a lot of the things that happened to
act
and in real life a lot of other
portrayals of this particular story
didn't get it as correct I'm watching
Braveheart soon's like that kind of
thing where it's like it's it it's a
good movie but it's not accurate at all
this was accurate with a lot of parts
the story is about Wyatt Earp who's
played by Kurt Russell he's just so good
in this and his two brothers who move
with their wives to a town the town of
Tombstone there's this great scene where
they first get to the town and they're
like what are we gonna do for money so
Kurt Russell walks into this bar and
beats up a chubby Billy Bob Thornton and
it was the weirdest thing because they
were pointing out the different actors
to me because I obviously don't know who
anyone is
do like that's Billy Bob Thornton I was
like no way is that Billy Bob Thornton
no way even a scene like realize that
it's him it still doesn't look like him
he was great though and like a very
small part of the movie there's all
these big-name actors who are just
slivers in this movie filled with think
an amazing line from Kurt Russell to
Billy Bob Thornton is you gonna do
something or you're just gonna stand
there and bleed and bleed
that's so intimidating so Wyatt Earp
fell in love with another woman while
married the herbs are portrayed as
heroes in this film and of course the
real-life story is that they were not
feel like The Shining heroes of the
story they they were good and they also
were bad in
certain way so this is one of those
where I was like okay you brought this
poor woman here and now you're just like
they portray her that she's also like
that so maybe that was the case - but
he's in love with this other woman and I
very much identify with her she says her
ideal best life is freedom and room
service and if that's not just yeah
that's yes that's what I want me to
feign so basically they're just living
in this town and there's a lot of crappy
things happening there's opium and
shootings and gambling and cowboys and
it sucks there's a lot more interesting
that I thought it was going to be one of
the best lines have ever heard delivered
ever in my life of watching film it's
not been long but ever val kilmer crazy
drunk saying I have two guns one for
each of you so good he's just the best
in he's absolutely the best character
for me well everyone's like oh it's his
best role by far like I mean I believe
it I don't have that much to gauge it
off of but I've believed it he was so
entertaining and it makes me want to
love him and watch all of his other
films but get the feeling but he's not
like beloved and how can you not be she
was so good at it so the Cowboys are
this gang that we're taking care of
hurting and and taking care of cattle
business and so they were kind of
allowed but they're shooting a lot of
people and they're not great for the
town and so the herbs come in and they
join the police force and they are going
to try to kind of help the town get
better and by doing that they they
enforce the gun control and the town is
up in arms about it literally they're
pissed about gun control and it's so
funny and like someone
topical that's people are dying left and
right in this town they're like you're
not taking my guns it is like well your
son was just murdered but okay that's
weird
Oh Kurt Russell you are acting your
heart out on Bill Paxton dying it was
incredible he died in this bar and Kurt
Russell sees it and he runs out into the
rain I honestly was not expecting to be
emotionally invested in a Western I I
know how stupid is that like obviously
people love them for a reason I just
watched my first samurai film too
recently and I loved it like branch out
of it Tamara just like expand yourself a
little bit you're gonna like finds new
things that you're obviously going to
love good she's just a really lovely
moments with Doc Holliday Val Kilmer's
role I just love he's dying of
tuberculosis has been since he was 15 I
think I want to say and so he just lives
his life to like the fullest he drinks
and Gamble's he's very smart he's a
well-educated man from Georgia and he is
very sick at one point and he asks Kurt
Russell what's it like wearing one of
those about his sheriff's badge and so
Kurt Russell gives a two minutes it's a
lovely moment and then he takes that and
he goes and kills the guy that's been
tormenting them this whole time and
that's another thing that's like
probably not how it actually happened
but super damn effective in the movie
for sure then Doc dies and it's
beautiful and this movie might be the
greatest collection of acting I've ever
seen it's truly something and
and I asked if it was nominated for
anything and I was told it wasn't
nominated for anything
no just the MTV Movie Awards Val Kilmer
oh good fellow good Kurt Russell's
character Wyatt Earp he goes and lives
with the woman that he fell in love with
and it turns out that she's the one who
wrote the book and like the definitive
life of Wyatt Earp and that's how they
have so much information on him now
she's incredibly interesting I really
really thought I was gonna be bored
which is such an indication of like why
I haven't seen films like this why
haven't seen so many films why I haven't
seen like Citizen Kane why I haven't
seen like like that it's like why
Tamra Oh cuz you thought it was gonna be
boring
ah I'm your huckleberry I love it every
time you said Val Kilmer is Doc Holliday
will definitely make you swoon even if
it's not historically accurate
you're gonna be surprised at how good
val kilmer is in this and like I'm not
cuz I don't know how he is regularly who
I what what should I my sermon I dare
you to even try hearing the word no
again without thinking of that thank you
so much for watching next week I'll see
you guys with Top Gun get into some Tom
Cruise here
and I'll see you guys soon thank you so
much
[Music]
[Applause]
you